DAVID SONTAG: A
three-part lecture today,
and I'm still continuing on
the theme of reinforcement
learning.
Part one, I'm going
to be speaking,
and I'll be following up
on last week's discussion
about causal inference
and Tuesday's discussion
on reinforcement learning.
And I'll be going into sort
of one more subtlety that
arises there and
where we can develop
some nice mathematical
methods to help with.
And then I'm going
to turn over the show
to Barbra, who I'll formally
introduce when the time comes.
And she's going to both
talk about some of her work
on developing and evaluating
dynamic treatment regimes,
and then she will
lead a discussion
on the sepsis paper,
which was required
reading from today's class.
So those are the three
parts of today's lecture.
So I want you to return
back, put yourself back
in the mindset of
Tuesday's lecture
where we talked about
reinforcement learning.
Now, remember that the goal
of reinforcement learning
was to optimize some reward.
Specifically, our goal is
to find some policy, which
I can note as pi
star, which is the arg
max over all possible
policies pi of v of pi,
where just to
remind you, v of pi
is the value of the policy pi.
Formally, it's defined as
the expectation of the sum
of the rewards across time.
So the reason why
I'm calling this
an expectation with like
the pi is because there's
stochasticity both in the
environment, and possibly pi
is going to be a
stochastic policy.
And this is summing
over the time steps,
because this is not just a
single time step problem.
But we're going to be
considering interventions
across time of the reward
at each point in time.
And that reward function could
either be at each point in time
or you might imagine that
this is 0 for all time steps,
except for the last time step.
So the first question I
want us to think about
is, well, what are
the implications
of this as a learning paradigm?
If we look what's going on
over here, hidden in my story
is also an expectation
over x, the patient,
for example, or
the initial state.
And so this
intuitively is saying,
let's try to find a policy
that has high expected
reward, average [INAUDIBLE]
over all patients.
And I just want you to think
about whether that is indeed
the right goal.
Can anyone think
about a setting where
that might not be desirable?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What if the reward
is the patient living or dying?
You don't want it
to have high ratings
like saving two
patients and [INAUDIBLE]
and expect the same [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID SONTAG: So what
happens if this reward
is something mission critical
like a patient dying?
You really want to try to
avoid that from happening
as much as possible.
Of course, there
are other criteria
that we might be
interested in as well.
And both in Frederick's lecture
on Tuesday and in the readings,
we talked about how there might
be other aspects about making
sure that a patient is not
just alive but also healthy,
which might play into
your reward functions.
And there might be rewards
associated with those.
And if you were to
just, for example,
put a positive or
negative infinity
for a patient dying,
that's a nonstarter,
right, because if you did that,
unfortunately in this world,
we're not always going to be
able to keep patients alive.
And so you're going to get
into an infeasible optimization
problem.
So minus infinity
is not an option.
We're going to have to
put some number to it
in this type of approach.
But then you're going to start
trading off between patients.
In some cases, you might
have a very high reward for--
there are two
different solutions
that you might
imagine, one solution
where the reward is somewhat
balanced across patients
and another situation
where you have
really small values of
reward for some patients
and a few patients with very
large values and rewards.
And both of them could be
the same average, obviously.
But both are not
necessarily equally useful.
We might want to say
that we prefer to avoid
that worst-case situation.
So one could imagine
other ways of formulating
this optimization
problem, like maybe you
want to control the
worst-case reward instead
of the average-case reward.
Or maybe you want
to say something
about different quartiles.
I just wanted to point that
out, because really that's
the starting place for a lot of
the work that we're doing here.
So now I want us
to think through,
OK, returning back to this goal,
we've done our policy iteration
or we've done our Q
learning, that is,
and we get a policy out.
And we might now
want to know what
is the value of that policy?
So what is our estimate
of that quantity?
Well, to get that,
one could just
try to read it off
from the results of Q
learning by just
computing that the pi--
what I'm calling v pi
hat-- the estimate is
just equal to now a
maximum over actions
a of your Q function
evaluated at whatever
your initial state is and the
optimal choice of action a.
So all I'm saying here is that
the last step of the algorithm
might be to ask, well,
what is the expected
reward of this policy?
And if you remember,
the Q learning algorithm
is, in essence, a dynamic
programming algorithm
working its way from the
sort of large values of time
up to the present.
And it is indeed actually
computing this expected value
that you're interested in.
So you could just read
it off from the Q values
at the very end.
But I want to point
out that here there's
an implicit policy built in.
So I'm going to compare this
in just a second to what
happens under the causal
inference scenario.
So just a single time
step in potential outcomes
framework that we're used to.
Notice that the value of this
policy, the reason why it's
a function of pi is
because the value
is a function of every
subsequent action
that you're taking as well.
And so now let's
just compare that
for a second to what happens
in the potential outcomes
framework.
So there, our starting place--
so now I'm going to turn
our attention for just one
moment from reinforcement
learning now back to just
causal inference.
In reinforcement learning,
we talked about policies.
How do we find
policies to do well
in terms of some expected
reward of this policy?
But yet when we were talking
about causal inference,
we only used words like
average treatment effect
or conditional average
treatment effect,
where for example, to estimate
the conditional average
treatment effect,
what we said is we're
going to first learn, if we
use a covariate adjustment
approach, we learn
some function f
of x comma t, which
is intended to be
an approximation of the expected
value of your outcome y given
x comma--
I'll say y of t.
There.
So that notation.
So the goal of
covariate adjustment
was to estimate this quantity.
And we could use that then
to try to construct a policy.
For example, you could think
about the policy pi of x,
which simply looks to see is--
we'll say it's 1 if CATE or
your estimate of CATE for x
is positive and 0 otherwise.
Just remind you, the way that
we got the estimate of CATE
for an individual x
was just by looking
at f of x comma 1
minus f of x comma 0.
So if we have a policy--
so now we're going to start
thinking about policies
in the context of
causal inference,
just like we were doing
in reinforcement learning.
And I want us to think through
what would the analogous value
of the policy be?
How good is that policy?
It could be another
policy, but right now I'm
assuming I'm just going
to focus on this policy
that I show up here.
Well, one approach
to try to evaluate
how good that policy is, is
exactly analogous to what we
did in reinforcement learning.
In essence, what
we're going to say
is we evaluate the
quality of the policy
by summing over your
empirical data of pi of xi.
So this is going to be 1 if the
policy says to give treatment 1
to individual xi.
In that case, we say that
the value is f of x comma 1.
Or if you gave the second--
if the policy would
give treatment 0,
the value of the policy on
that individual is 1 minus pi
of x times f of x comma 0.
So I'm going to call this
sort of an empirical estimate
of what you should think about
as the reward for a policy pi.
And it's exactly analogous
to the estimate of v of pie
that you would get from a
reinforcement learning context.
But now we're talking
about policies explicitly.
So let's try to dig
down a little bit deeper
and think about what
this is actually saying.
Imagine the story where you
just have a single covariate x.
We'll think about x as being,
let's say, the patient's age.
And unfortunately there's
just one color here.
But I'll do my best with that.
And imagine that the
potential outcome
y0 as a function of
the patient's age x
looks like this.
Now imagine that the
other potential outcome
y1 looked like that.
So I'll call this the
y1 potential outcome.
Suppose now that the policy
that we're defining is this.
So we're going to
give treatment one
if the condition of our
treatment effect is positive
and 0 otherwise.
I want everyone to draw what
the value of that policy
is on a piece of paper.
It's going to be--
I'm sorry-- I want everyone
to write on a piece of paper
what the value of the policy
would be for each individual.
So it's going to
be a function of x.
And now I want it to be--
I'm looking for y of pi of x.
So I'm looking for
you to draw that plot.
And feel free to talk
to your neighbor.
In fact, I encourage you
to talk to your neighbor.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
Just to try to connect
this a little bit better
to what I have up here, I'm
going to assume that f--
this is f of x1,
and this is f of x0.
All right.
Any guesses?
What does this plot look like?
Someone who hasn't spoken in
the last one week and a half,
if possible.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does it take like
the max of the functions
at all point, like,
it would be y0 up
until they intersect
and then y1 afterward?
DAVID SONTAG: So it would
be something like this
until the intersection point.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID SONTAG: And then
like that afterwards.
Yeah.
That's exactly
what I'm going for.
And let's try to
think through why is
that the value of the policy?
Well, here the CATE,
which is looking
at a difference between
these two lines as negative--
so for every x up to
this crossing point,
the policy that we've
defined over there
is going to perform action--
wait.
Am I drawing this correctly?
Maybe it's actually
the opposite, right?
This should be doing action one.
Here.
OK.
So here the CATE is negative.
And so by my definition, the
action performed is action 0.
And so the value of the
policy is actually this one.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAVID SONTAG: Oh.
Wait.
Oh, good.
[INAUDIBLE]
Because this is the
graph I have in my notes.
Oh, good.
OK.
I was getting worried.
So it's this action, all the
way up until you get over here.
And then over here, now the
CATE suddenly becomes positive.
And so the action chosen is 1.
And so the value of
that policy is y1.
So one could write this a
little bit differently for--
in the case of just
two policies, and now
I'm going to write this in a
way that it's really clear.
In the case of just
two actions, one
could write this
equivalently as an average
over the data points of
the maximum of fx comma 0
and f of x comma 1.
And this simplification turning
this formula into this formula
is making the
assumption that the pi
that we're being evaluated
on is precisely this pi.
So this simplification
is only for that pi.
For another policy, which is not
looking at CATE or for example,
which might threshold
CATE at a gamma,
it wouldn't quite be this.
It would be something else.
But I've gone a
step further here.
So what I've shown
you right here
is not the average value but
sort of individual values.
I have shown you
the max function.
But what this is
actually looking
at is the expected reward, which
is now averaging across all x.
So to truly draw a connection
between this plot we're drawing
and the average reward
of that policy, what
we should be looking
at is the average
of these two functions, which is
we'll say something like that.
And that value is
the expected reward.
Now, this all goes to show
that the expected reward
of this policy is not a
quantity that we've considered
in the previous
lectures, at least
not in the previous lectures
in causal inference.
This is not the same as
the average treatment
effect, for example.
So I've just given you
one way to think through,
number one, what is
the policy that you
might want to derive when
you're doing causal inference?
And number two, what
is one way to estimate
the value of that
policy, which goes
through the process of
estimating potential outcomes
via covariate adjustment?
But we might wonder,
just like when
we talked about in
causal inference
where I said there are two
approaches or more than two,
but we focused on two,
using covariate adjustment
and doing inverse
propensity score weighting,
you might wonder is
there another approach
to this problem all together?
Is there an approach
which wouldn't
have had to go
through estimating
the potential outcomes?
And that's what
I'll spend the rest
of this third of the lecture
focused talking about.
And so to help you
page this back in,
remember that we derived
in last Thursday's lecture
an estimator for the average
treatment effect, which
was 1 over n times the
sum over data points
that got treatment 1 of yi, the
observed outcome for that data
point, divided by
the propensity score,
which I'm just going
to write as ei.
So ei is equal to
the probability
of observing t equals
1 given the data point
xi minus a sum over data
point i such that ti equals
0 of yi divided by 1 minus ei.
And by the way, there was
a lot of confusion in class
why do I have a 1 over
n here, a 1 over n here,
but right now I just
took it out all together,
and not 1 over the
number of positive points
and 1 over the number
of 0 data points.
And I expanded the derivation
that I gave in class,
and I posted new slides
online after class.
So if you're curious about
that, go to those slides
and look at the derivation.
So in a very
analogous way now, I'm
going to give you
a new estimator
for this same quantity
that I had over here,
the expected reward of a policy.
Notice that this estimator here,
it made sense for any policy.
It didn't have to be the
policy which looked at,
is CATE just greater
than 0 or not?
This held for any policy.
The simplification
I gave was only
in this particular setting.
I'm going to give you
now another estimator
for the average value
of a policy, which
doesn't go through estimating
potential outcomes at all.
Analogous to this is
just going to make
use of the propensity scores.
And I'll call it R hat.
Now I'm going to put
a superscript IPW
for inverse propensity weighted.
And it's a function of
pi, and it's given to you
by the following formula--
1 over n sum over the data
points of an indicator
function for if the
treatment, which was actually
given to the i-th
patient, is equal to what
the policy would have done
before the i-th patient.
And by the way, here
I'm assuming that pi
is a deterministic function.
So the policy says
for this patient,
you should do this treatment.
So we're going to
look at just the data
points for which the
observed treatment is
consistent with what
the policy would
have done for that patient.
And this indicator
function is 0 otherwise.
And we're going to divide it by
the probability of ti given xi.
So the way I'm writing this,
by the way, is very general.
So this formula will hold for
nonbinary treatments as well.
And that's one of the
really nice things
about thinking about
policies, which
is whereas when talking about
average treatment effect,
average treatment effect
sort of makes sense
in the comparative sense,
comparing one to another.
But when we talk about
how good is a policy,
it's not a comparative
statement at all.
The policy does
something for everyone.
You could ask, well, what is the
average value of the outcomes
that you get for those
actions that we're
taking for those individuals?
So that's why I'm writing a
slightly more general fashion
already here.
Times yi obviously.
So this is now a new estimator.
I'm not going to derive
it for you in class,
but the derivation is
very similar to what
we did last week when we tried
to drive the average treatment
effect.
And the critical point is we're
dividing by that propensity
score, just like
we did over there.
So this, if all of the
assumptions made sense,
you had infinite
data, should give you
exactly the same
estimate as this.
But here, you're not estimating
potential outcomes at all.
So you never have to try to
impute the counterfactuals.
Here, all it relies
on knowing is
that you have the
propensity scores
for each of the data
points in your training set
or in a data set.
So for example,
this opens the door
to tons of new
exciting directions.
Imagine that you had a very
large observational data set.
And you learned
a policy from it.
For example, you might have
done covariate adjustment
and then said, OK, based
on covariate adjustment,
this is my new policy.
So you might have gotten
it via that approach.
Now you want to know
how good is that.
Well, suppose that you then
run a randomized control trial.
And then you run a
randomized control trial,
you have 100 people, maybe 200
people, and so not that many.
So not nearly enough
people to have
actually estimated
your policy alone.
You might have needed thousands
or millions of individuals
to estimate your policy.
Now you're only going to
have a couple individuals
that you could actually afford
to do a randomized control
trial on.
For those people,
because you're flipping
a coin for which treatment
they're going to get,
suppose that were
in a binary setting
where the only two
treatments, then this value
is always 1/2 1/2.
And what I'm giving
you here is going
to be an unbiased estimate
of how good that policy is,
which one can now estimate using
that randomized control trial.
Now, this also might
lead you to think
through the question of,
well, rather than estimating
the policy through--
rather than obtaining a policy
through the lens of optimizing
CATE, of figuring
how to estimate CATE,
maybe we could have
skipped that all together.
For example, suppose that we had
that randomized control trial
data.
Now imagine that rather
than 100 individuals,
you had a really large
randomized control trial
with 10,000 individuals in it.
This now opens the door
to thinking about directly
maximizing or minimizing,
depending whether you want this
to be large or small,
pi with respect
to this quantity, which
completely bypasses
the goal of estimating the
condition of average treatment
effect.
And you'll notice how
this looks exactly
like a classification problem.
This quantity here looks
exactly like a 0 1 loss.
And the only difference
is that you're
weighting each of
the data points
by this inverse propensity.
So one can reduce the
problem of actually finding
an optimal policy here to that
of a weighted classification
problem, in the case of a
discrete set of treatments.
There are two big caveats
to that line of thinking.
The first major
caveat is that you
have to know these
propensity scores.
And so if you have data coming
from randomized control trial,
you will know this
propensity scores
or if you have, for
example, some control
over the data
generation process.
For example, if you
are an ad company
and you get to choose which
ad to show to your customers,
then you look to see
who clicks on what,
you might know what that policy
was that was showing things.
In that case, you might exactly
know the propensity scores.
In health care, other than
in randomized control trials,
we typically don't
know this value.
So we either have to have a
large enough randomized control
trial that we won't over-fit
by trying to directly minimize
this or we have to work within
an observational data setting.
But we have to estimate the
propensity scores directly.
So you would then have
a two-step procedure,
where first you estimate these
propensity scores, for example,
by doing logistic regression.
And then you attempt
to maximize or minimize
this quantity in order to
find the optimal policy.
And that has a
lot of challenges,
because this quantity
shown in the very bottom
here could be really
small or really large
in an observational data set
due to these issues of having
very small overlap
between your treatments.
And this being very
small implies then
that the variant of this
estimator is very, very large.
And so when one wants to
use an approach like this,
similar to when one wants to
use an average treatment effect
estimator, and when you're
estimating these propensities,
often you might
need to do things
like clipping of the
propensity scores
in order to prevent the
variants from being too large.
That then, however, leads to
a biased estimate typically.
I wanted to give you a
couple of references here.
So one is Swaminathan
and Joachims,
J-O-A-C-H-I-M-S ACML 2015.
In that paper, they
tackle this question.
They focus on the setting
where the propensity scores are
known, such as do it half from
a randomized controlled trial.
And they recognize
that you might
decide that you prefer something
like a biased estimator because
of the fact that these
propensity scores could
be really small.
And so they use some
generalization results
from the machine learning
theory community in order
to try to control the
variants of the estimator
as a function of these
propensity scores.
And they then learn,
directly minimize
the policy which is what they
call counterfactual regret
minimization, in
order to allow one
to generalize as
best as possible
from the small amount of data
you might have available.
A second reference that
I want to give just
to point you into this
literature, if you're
interested, is by Nathan
Kallus and his student,
I believe Angela Zhou,
from NeurIPS 2018.
And that was a paper which was
one of the optional readings
for last Thursday's class.
Now, that paper they
also start from something
like this, from
this perspective.
And they say that,
oh, now that we're
working in this
framework, one could
think about what happens
if you have actually
unobserved confounding.
So there, you might not actually
know the true propensity
scores, because there are
unobserved confounders
that you don't observe.
And that you can think about
trying to bound how wrong
your estimator can be as
a function of how much you
don't know this quantity.
And they show that
when you try to--
if you think about having
some backup strategy,
like if your goal is to find
a new policy which performs
as best as possible with
respect to an old policy,
then it gives you a
really elegant framework
for trying to think about a
robust optimization of this,
even taking into consideration
the fact that there might
be unobserved confounding.
And that works also
in this framework.
So I'm nearly done now.
I just want to now
finish with a thought,
can we do the same thing
for policies learned
by reinforcement learning?
So now that we've sort
of built up this language
that's returned
to the RL setting.
And there one can
show that you can
get a similar estimate
for the value of a policy
by summing over your
observed sequences,
summing over the time steps
of that sequence of the reward
observed at that time step times
a ratio of probabilities, which
is going from the
first time step up
to time little t
of the probability
that you would actually take
the observed action t prime,
given that you are in the
observed state t prime, divided
by the probability--
this is the analogy
of the propensity
score, the probability under
the data generating process--
of seeing action a given that
you are in state t prime.
So if, as we
discussed there, you
had a deterministic
policy, then this pi,
it would just be
a delta function.
And so this would
just be looking at--
this estimator would
only be looking
at sequences where the precise
sequence of actions taken
are identical to the
precise sequence of actions
that the policy
would have taken.
And the difference here
is that now instead
of having a single
propensity score,
one has a product of these
propensity scores corresponding
to the propensity of
observing that action given
the corresponding state at
each point along the sequence.
And so this is nice,
because this gives you
one way to do what's called
off-policy evaluation.
And this is an
estimator, which is
completely analogous
to the estimator
that we got from Q learning.
So if all assumptions
were correct,
and you had a lot of
data, then those two
should give you precisely
the same answer.
But here, like in the
causal inference setting,
we are not making the
assumption that we can
do covariate adjustment well.
Or said differently,
we're not assuming that we
can fit the Q function well.
And this is now,
just like there,
based on the assumption
that we have the ability
to really accurately know what
the propensity scores are.
So it now gives you an
alternative approach
to do evaluation.
And you could
think about looking
at the robustness
of your estimates
from these two
different estimators.
And this is the most
naive of the estimators.
There are many ways to try
to make this better, such as
by doing w robust estimators.
And if you want to
learn more, I recommend
reading this paper by Thomas
and Emma Brunskill in ICML 2016.
And with that, I want Barbra
to come up and get set up.
And we're going to transition
to the next part of the lecture.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why do we sum
over t and take the project
across all t?
DAVID SONTAG: One easy
way to think about this
is suppose that you only had a
reward of the last time step.
If you only had a reward
of the last time step,
then you wouldn't
have this sum over t,
because the rewards in the
earlier steps would be 0.
You would just have that
product going from 0 up
to capital T of last time step.
The reason why you have
it up to at each time step
is because one wants to be
able to appropriately weigh
the likelihood of seeing that
reward at that point in time.
One could rewrite
this in other ways.
I want to hold other
questions, because this part
of the lecture is going to
be much more interesting
than my part of the lecture.
And with that, I want
introduce Barbra.
Barbra, I first met her
when she invited me to give
a talk in her class last year.
She's an instructor at
Harvard Medical School--
or School of Public Health.
She recently finished
her PhD in 2018.
And her PhD looked
at many questions
related to the themes of
the last couple of weeks.
Since that time, in addition
continuing her research,
she's been really leading the
way in creating data science
curriculum over at Harvard.
So please take it away.
BARBRA DICKERMAN:
Thank you so much
for the introduction, David.
I'm very happy to be here
to share some of my work
on evaluating dynamic
treatment strategies,
which you've been talking about
over the past few lectures.
So my goals for
today, I'm just going
to breeze over defining
dynamic treatment strategies,
as you're already
familiar with it.
But I would like
to touch on when
we need a special class of
methods called g-methods.
And then we'll talk about
two different applications,
different analyses, that
have focused on evaluating
dynamic treatment strategies.
So the first will
be an application
of the parametric
g-formula, which
is a powerful g-method
to cancer research.
And so the goal
here is to give you
my causal inference
perspective on how
we think about this task of
sequential decision making
and then with
whatever time remains,
we'll be discussing a recent
publication on the AI clinician
to talk through the
reinforcement learning
perspective.
So I think it'll be a really
interesting discussion, where
we can share these
perspectives, talk
about the relative strengths
and limitations as well.
And please stop me if
you have any questions.
So you already know this.
When it comes to
treatment strategies,
there's three main types.
There's point
interventions happening
at a single point in time.
There's sustained interventions
happening over time.
When it comes to clinical
care, this is often
what we're most interested in.
Within that, there
are static strategies,
which are constant over time.
And then there's
dynamic strategies,
which we're going to focus on.
And these differ in that
the intervention over time
depends on evolving
characteristics.
So for example, initiate
treatment at baseline
and continue it over follow
up until a contraindication
occurs, at which point
you may stop treatment
and decide with your
doctor whether you're
going to switch to an
alternate treatment.
You would still be
adhering to that strategy,
even though you quit.
The comparison here being do
not initiate treatment over
follow up, likewise unless
an indication occurs,
at which point you may
start treatment and still
be adhering to the strategy.
So we're focusing on
these because they're
the most clinically relevant.
And so clinicians encounter
these every day in practice.
So when they're making
a recommendation
to their patient about a
prevention intervention,
they're going to be
taking into consideration
the patient's evolving
comorbidities.
Or when they're deciding
the next screening interval,
they'll consider the previous
result from the last screening
test when deciding that.
Likewise for treatment, deciding
whether to keep the patient
on treatment or not.
Is the patient
having any changes
in symptoms or lab values
that may reflect toxicity?
So one thing to note
is that while many
of the strategies that you
may see in clinical guidelines
and in clinical practice
are dynamic strategies,
these may not be the
optimal strategies.
So maybe what we're
recommending and doing
is not optimal for patients.
However, the optimal
strategies will
be dynamic in some
way, in that they
will be adapting to
individuals' unique and evolving
characteristics.
So that's why we
care about them.
So what's the problem?
So one problem
deals with something
called treatment
confounder feedback,
which you may have spoken
about in this class.
So conventional statistical
methods cannot appropriately
compare dynamic treatment
strategies in the presence
of treatment
confounder feedback.
So this is when time
varying confounders are
affected by previous treatment.
So if we kind of ground
this in a concrete example
with this causal
diagram, let's say
we're interested in estimating
the effect of some intervention
A, vasopressors or it could be
IV fluids, on some outcome Y,
which we'll call survival here.
We know that vasopressors
affect blood pressure,
and blood pressure will
affect subsequent decisions
to treat with vasopressors.
We also know that
hypotension-- so again,
blood pressure, L1,
affects survival, based
on our clinical knowledge.
And then in this DAG, we
also have the node U, which
represents disease severity.
So these could be potentially
unmeasured markers
of disease severity that are
affecting your blood pressure
and also affecting your
probability of survival.
So if we're interested
in estimating
the effect of a sustained
treatment strategy,
then we want to know something
about the total effect
of treatment at all time points.
We can see that L1 here is a
confounder for the effect of A1
on Y so we have to do
something to adjust for that.
And if we were to apply a
conventional statistical
method, we would essentially
be conditioning on a collider
and inducing a selection bias.
So an open path from
A0 to L1 to U to Y.
What's the consequence of this?
If we look in our
data set, we may
see an association
between A and Y.
But that association is not
because there's necessarily
an effect of A on Y.
It might not be causal.
It may be due to this
selection bias that we created.
So this is the problem.
And so in these cases, we
need a special type of method
that can handle these settings.
And so a class of methods
that was designed specifically
to handle this is g-methods.
And so these are sometimes
referred to as causal methods.
They've been developed by
Jamie Robins and colleagues
and collaborators since 1986.
And they include the
parametric g-formula,
g-estimation of
structural nested models,
and inverse
probability weighting
of marginal structural models.
So in my research,
what I do is I
combine g-methods with
large longitudinal databases
to try to evaluate dynamic
treatment strategies.
So I'm particularly interested
in bringing these methods
to cancer research,
because they haven't
been applied much there.
So a lot of my
research questions
are focused on answering
questions like,
how and when can we intervene to
best prevent, detect, and treat
cancer?
And so I'd like to share
one example with you, which
focused on evaluating
the effect of adhering
to guideline-based
physical activity
interventions on survival
among men with prostate cancer.
So the motivation
for this study,
there's a large clinical
organization, ASCO,
the American Society
of Clinical Oncology,
that had actually called
for randomized trials
to generate these estimates
for several cancers.
The thing with
prostate cancer is
it's a very slowly
progressing disease.
So the feasibility of doing
a trial to evaluate this
is very limited.
The trial would have to
be 10 years long probably.
So given that, given the absence
of this randomized evidence,
we did the next
best thing that we
could do to generate
this estimate, which
was combine high-quality
observational data
with advanced EPI methods, in
this case parametric g-formula.
And so we leveraged data
from the Health Professionals
Follow-up Study, which is a
well-characterized prospective
cohort study.
So in these cases, there's
a three-step process
that we take to extract the
most meaningful and actionable
insights from
observational data.
So the first thing
that we do is we
specify the protocol
of the target trial
that we would have liked to
conduct had it been feasible.
The second thing we
do is we make sure
that we measure enough
covariates to approximately
adjust for confounding
and achieve
conditional exchangeability.
And then the third
thing we do is
we apply an appropriate method
to compare the specified
treatment strategies
under this assumption
of conditional exchangeability.
And so in this case,
eligible men for this study
had been diagnosed with
non-metastatic prostate cancer.
And at baseline,
they were free of
cardiovascular and
neurologic conditions that
may limit physical ability.
For the treatment
strategies, men
were to initiate one of
six physical activity
strategies at diagnosis and
continue it over followup
until the development
of a condition limiting
physical activity.
So this is what made
the strategies dynamic.
The intervention
over time depended
on these evolving conditions.
And so just to note,
we pre-specified
these strategies that
we were evaluating
as well as the conditions.
Men were followed
until diagnosis,
until death, and to followup
10 years after diagnosis
or administrative
end to followup,
whichever happened first.
Our outcome of interest
was all cause mortality
within 10 years.
And we were interested in
estimating the per protocol
effect of not just
initiating these strategies
but adhering to
them over followup.
And again, we applied
the parametric g-formula.
So I think you've already
heard about the g-formula
in a previous lecture, possibly
in a slightly different way.
So I won't spend too
much time on this.
So the g-formula, essentially
the way I think about it
is a generalization
of standardization
to time varying exposures
and confounders.
So it's basically
a weighted average
of risks, where you can
think of the weights being
the probability density
functions of the time varying
confounders, which we estimate
using parametric regression
models.
And we approximate
the weighted average
using Monte Carlo simulation.
So practically
how do we do this?
So the first thing we do is
we fit parametric regression
models for all of the
variables that we're
going to be studying.
So for treatment confounders
and death at each followup time.
The next thing we do is
Monte Carlo simulation
where essentially
what we want to do
is simulate the
outcome distribution
under each treatment strategy
that we're interested in.
And then we bootstrap
the confidence intervals.
So I'd like to show you
kind of in a schematic what
this looks like,
because it might
be a little bit easier to see.
So again, the idea
is we're going
to make copies of our data
set, where in each copy
everyone is adhering
to the strategy
that we're focusing
on in that copy.
So how do we construct each of
these copies of the data set?
We have to build them
each from the ground up,
starting with time 0.
So the values of all of the time
varying covariates at time 0
are sampled from their
empirical distribution.
So these are actually observed
values of the covariates.
How do we get the values
at the next time point?
We use the parametric
regression models
that I mentioned that
we fit in step 1.
Then what we do is we force
the level of the intervention
variable to be whatever was
specified by that intervention
strategy.
And then we estimate
the risk of the outcome
at each time period
given these variables,
again using the
parametric regression
model for the outcome now.
And so we repeat this
over all time periods
to estimate a cumulative risk
under that strategy, which
is taken as the average of
the subject-specific risks.
So this is what I'm doing.
This is kind of
under the hood what's
going on with this method.
DAVID SONTAG: So
maybe we should try
to put that in language of
what we saw in the class.
And let me know if I'm
getting this wrong.
So you first estimate the
markup decision process,
which allows you to simulate
from the underlying data
distribution.
So you know that probability
of this sort of next sequence
of observations, given the
previous sequence and action
and previous actions,
and then with that, then
you could then intervene
and simulate the forms.
Because that was,
if you remember
Frederick gave you
three different buckets
of approaches.
Then he focused
on the middle one.
This is the left-most bucket.
The right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID SONTAG: So we
didn't talk about it.
AUDIENCE: No, [INAUDIBLE]
model based on relevance.
BARBRA DICKERMAN: Yeah.
Yes.
DAVID SONTAG: But
it's very sensible.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But it seems very hard.
BARBRA DICKERMAN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Oh, it seems very hard to
model this [INAUDIBLE]..
BARBRA DICKERMAN: Yeah.
So that is a challenge.
That is the hardest
part about this.
And it's relying on a
lot of assumptions, yeah.
So the primary
results that kind of
come out after we
do all of this.
So this is the estimated
risk of all cause mortality
under several physical
activity interventions.
So I'm not going to focus
too much on the results.
I want to focus on two main
takeaways from this slide.
One thing to emphasize
is we pre-specified
the weekly duration
of physical activity.
Or you can think of this like
the dose of the intervention.
We pre-specified that.
And this was based on
current guidelines.
So the third row
of each band, we
did look at some dose or
level beyond the guidelines
to see if there might be
additional survival benefits.
But these were
all pre-specified.
We also pre-specified all of
the time varying covariates
that made these
strategies dynamic.
So I mentioned that
men were excused
from following the
recommended physical activity
levels if they developed one
of these listed conditions,
metastasis, MI,
stroke, et cetera.
We pre-specified all of those.
It's possible that maybe
a different dependence
on a different time
varying covariate
may have led to a
more optimal strategy.
There was a lot that
remained unexplored.
So we did a lot of
sensitivity analyses
as part of this project.
I'd like to focus, though,
on the sensitivity analyses
that we did for potential
unmeasured confounding
by chronic disease that
may be severe enough
to affect both physical
activity and survival.
And so the g-formula is
actually providing a natural way
to at least partly
address this by estimating
the risk of these physical
activity interventions that
are at each time
point t only applied
to men who are healthy enough
to maintain a physical activity
level at that time.
And so again in
the main analysis,
we excused men from following
the recommended levels
if they developed one of
these serious conditions.
So in sensitivity
analyses, we then
expanded this list
of serious conditions
to also include the conditions
that are shown in blue text.
And so this attenuated
our estimates
but didn't change
our conclusions.
One thing to point out is that
the validity of this approach
rests on the assumption
that at each time t
we had available data
needed to identify which
men were healthy
at that time enough
to do the physical activity.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
just to double-check,
does excuse mean
that you remove them?
BARBRA DICKERMAN:
Great question.
So because the strategy
was pre-specified to say
that if you develop one
of these conditions,
you may essentially do whatever
level of physical activity
you're able to do.
So importantly-- I'm glad
you brought this up--
we did not censor
men at that time.
They were still followed,
because they were still
adhering to the
strategy as defined.
Thanks for asking.
And so given that we don't
know whether the data contain
at each time t the
information necessary to know,
are these men healthy enough
at that time, we therefore
conducted a few alternate
analyses in which we
lagged physical activity and
covariate data by two years.
And we also used a
negative outcome control
to explore potential unmeasured
confounding by clinical disease
or disease severity.
So what's the
rationale behind this?
So in the DAGs below for
the original analysis,
we have physical activity
A. We have survival Y.
And this may be confounded
by disease severity U.
So when we see an association
between A and Y in our data,
we want to make sure
that it's causal,
that it's because
of the blue arrow,
and not because of
this confounding bias,
the red arrow.
So how can we
potentially provide
evidence for whether that
red pathway is there?
We selected
questionnaire nonresponse
as an alternate outcome,
instead of survival,
that we assumed was not directly
affected by physical activity,
but that we thought would
be similarly confounded
by disease severity.
And so when we
repeated the analysis
with a negative
outcome control, we
found that physical activity
had a nearly null effect
on questionnaire nonresponse,
as we would expect,
which provides some support
that in our original analysis,
the effect of physical
activity on death
was not confounded through
the pathways explored
through the negative control.
So one thing to highlight
here is the sensitivity
analyses were driven by our
subject matter knowledge.
And there's nothing in the
data that kind of drove this.
And so just to
recap this portion.
So g-methods are a
useful tool, because they
let us validly
estimate the effect
of pre-specified
dynamic strategies
and estimate adjusted absolute
risks, which are clinically
meaningful to us, and
appropriately adjusted survival
curves, even in the presence
of treatment confounder
feedback, which occurs
often in clinical questions.
And of course, this is under
our typical identifiability
assumptions.
So this makes it a
powerful approach
to estimate the effects
of currently recommended
or proposed strategies
that therefore we
can specify and write out
precisely as we did here.
However, these
pre-specified strategies
may not be the
optimal strategies.
So again, when I was
doing this analysis,
I was thinking there are so
many different weekly durations
of physical activity that
we're not looking at.
There are so many different
time-varying covariates
where we could have different
dependencies on those
for these strategies over time.
And maybe those would have
led to better survival
outcomes among these men, but
all of that was unexplored.